- Good morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is Believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn how you
can focus on the right people.
Over to you, Trevor Noah.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Well, you have to find the
people, that are for you,
you have to understand whenever
you're creating a product,
whether it's music, whether
it's comedy, whether it's TV,
you're not trying to make it for everyone,
you're trying to find the people,
that you're trying to make it for.
You've got to stick to your truth
and then you find those
people and you believe in it,
so you go, "Is it good?"
and then I understand, I go,
"So, your lady and her Mom are watching?"
and then even if you're hating on me,
then I go, "Fine, then it's not for you,"
I know you're not--
- Fuck that guy, that guy.
- but I go, "Yeah, you're
not, but I have to focus
"on the people who are
watching me 10 times
"and I'm going to keep on
building on those people."
So at the end of the day,
if you focus on the people,
that are trying to block you,
you don't spend enough
time enjoying the people,
that are celebrating you.
- That's right.
If you want to have success,
then you need to pay careful
attention to the environment,
that you have around for yourself.
If you are surrounded by people,
who are telling you that you can't do it,
that you suck, that it's
never going to work,
that you don't have the
skills or the education
or the money or whatever reason,
you will never be a success,
because of all these
logical, practical things.
If you're surrounded by those people,
then guess what happens?
Nothing happens.
You don't go off and do the big thing,
because you're constantly
surrounded by negativity.
It's why so many people just
are the average of their
five friends, right,
so look at who your five friends are
and do you want to be like that or not?
Now, it doesn't mean that you
have to completely cut them off,
it doesn't mean that you need to,
you know, shun your family,
but you need to start creating
a more supportive
environment for yourself.
You may be saying, "But Evan, I don't know
"any more successful people,
"I don't know how to break free,
"I'm in a crappy area
"and everybody around
me tells me that I suck
"and I don't know who
else to go and turn to."
This is the first of your many challenges,
that you will come across
as an entrepreneur.
It's always going to be about
creatively solving problems.
It's about how resourceful you can be,
instead of how many resources you have.
So here's the first challenge,
"I don't know any successful people,
"what am I going to go out and do?
"Who am I going to turn to for advice?"
The first person I turned to to advise
in my business was my banker.
I didn't know anybody,
I had no connections,
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur,
I didn't know who to talk to,
so I went to my banker and I said,
"Hi, I'm Evan, I have a
business bank account with you.
"I'd love to know how you might be able
"to help my business.
"Any ideas you have would be fantastic."
He said, "Well, do you need a loan
"or do you need financing?"
I was like, "I dunno,
maybe, I don't know,"
"I'm trying to figure it out.
"I'm just starting,
"trying to figure out what
I'm doing with my company,
"I'd love your advice and input."
He's like, "Well, that's
not what we do, as a bank.
"You know, we give out loans."
I thought banks were, you know,
the friends of entrepreneurs.
So this is how naive I was, right
and this is how little knowledge I had
and how few connections I had,
that I went to my banker, you know,
but one conversation leads
to another conversation
leads to another conversation
and another conversation.
You're not going to get
the supportive environment
by just sitting on your couch, right,
you've got to go out and
start talking to people
and connecting and
understanding, asking for help.
People love to help,
but the risk is you're
not going to do any work.
If you come to me and you ask me for help,
I'm jaded, because of all the people,
who've asked me for help
and I gave them advice,
that they did nothing with.
So you're immediately
lumped in with those people.
So what you want to do is ask
for just a tiny bit of time.
Ask for one little bit of advice
and promise and show your hustle,
promise that you're going
to do the work on it
and then when you get
the advice, do the work
and then come back and say,
"Listen, I took that advice."
Don't go and ask for a mentor.
They don't want to commit
to a relationship with you.
One bit of advice, I
used two fingers there,
one bit of advice
(laughs), one on each hand,
and then go and do the work and come back
and say, "Listen, I did
this work and it worked!"
or, "didn't work, I tried, I
did hours and hours and hours
"and it didn't work out.
"How do I make it better?"
If they see that you're
taking the initiative
and actually executing, now
you're starting to ascend up.
There's other ways to be
surrounded by people though too,
it's not just mentorship,
join a Meet Up group,
connect with online communities,
we have an awesome online
community here on Believe Nation,
where people are supporting each other
and try to help each
other with their business,
join other online groups,
learn from virtual mentors.
One of the things that helped me the most
and me thinking bigger
and wanted to play on a different level
and thinking I could do
more and really feeling
like I could have a big
impact on this world,
one of the things, that helped me most
was my own YouTube channel.
It's selfish for me that
I'm sharing it with you,
it's a selfish endeavor for
me, that I share with you guys
and I'm so grateful and so
happy, that you enjoy it too.
When I'm around constantly
Elon Musk and Steve Jobs
and Oprah Winfrey and all these people,
who have done amazing things
and are still pushing to try to be better,
when I'm in that environment,
I want to do bigger things, I
want to have a much bigger impact.
So the more I'm around that,
the more it shifts my focus,
it shifts my attention
and makes me feel like
I can contribute more
and it builds a new
environment for myself.
If you want to do great things,
you need to create an
environment of greatness,
otherwise it's never going to work.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what kind of people do
you have in your life
and are they the right people to help you
get to where you need to go.
What changes are you going to make,
after watching this video?
I'm curious, leave it down
in the Comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Dave Gardner
from thedavegardner.com.
Dave, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, doing a
review, taking a picture,
I really, really appreciate it, man
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is, much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter keys clicking)
- You're happy with it though?
- I'm real happy with it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- When I see this thing play
in front of an audience,
people go crazy.
- Oh yeah.
What's your, what is one of those
Inside the Actors Studio for us,
like so what's your
process, once you do this,
you want to watch it with
all the audience here,
you don't want to see it, you study this,
what's your process, once you,
once they say, "Cut! That's a wrap."
- You know what, you cut it up, you know,
you've got to watch it with an audience,
it's not drama.
- Right.
- Drama is whatever you want it to be.
When you make drama, you are like Picasso
you're just like, "OK, whatever."
When you make comedy, you're
not that kind of painter,
you're like a painter
down at the promenade,
painting portraits of people,
you know what I'm saying,
"Oh, you want more blue in your eyes?
"I'm going to put more blue in your eyes.
(laughing)
"You want to be taller?
"Okay, you're taller."
You know, I'm one of those guys.
- Right.
- So that's, when you make comedy,
you make it for the
people and I, you know,
you try to have as many
screenings and as many tests
and you do focus groups
and you read the card,
so you try to give the
people what they want
and that's comedy, man.
- Yeah.
- People ask me from time to time,
"Do you make a movie with
an audience in mind?"
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- and my answer is, "Yes, I do."
alright, but the audience I have in mind
isn't some faceless blobs, that
I'm trying to second guess,
(laughs) alright,
- Yeah.
- It's me.
- [Interviewer] You
sound like a focus group.
- Yeah, it's me, I'm the audience,
I'm the guy that goes out
and pays seven dollars
or eight dollars in New York, (laughs)
you know, to go and see a movie, alright.
I go so, if I'm excited
about seeing a movie,
I see it on opening day, alright,
I am the audience, alright,
and I know what I want to see,
you know, and I was betting
and I was a little surprised
at how many there were,
I was betting that there were other people
like me out there, alright.
Now true, I'm making specific films
and if you make a specific film,
that's not everything for everybody,
you're going to turn
some people off, alright,
but you're going to
turn some people on too.
- In the old day, when I
start the action movies,
I just make audience laughing, you know,
do all the funny things, you
know, ah, like, ohh, like this
and kick their ball in
(audience laughing).
So that's a?
- It is really, yeah.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, but slowly,
slowly, from the audience,
from the audience,
(laughs) from the media,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Especially from the fans,
they write the letter,
"Oh, now I have a baby, so
sad I cannot see the movie,
"because the dirty word, but
because the dirty action,
"because this,"
all those years, I change,
change, change, change, change,
but without all the dirty things,
still can make the audience
laughing, that's the difficult.
It's the audience, all
the fans, all the media,
teach me becoming a good filmmaker.